[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news coming up on today's
program
we take a look at what effect the
climate crisis has on the movement of
refugees across the world
a shortage of coal leads to a dip in
china's carbon emissions
and pakistan authorities look for ways
to reduce emissions as lahore is named
the most polluted city in the world this
week
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
the mass movement of refugees into
europe is dominating headlines once
again many of them are fleeing conflict
and persecution in their own countries
but across the world there is now
increasing evidence that climate change
is a factor the internal displacement
monitoring center earlier this year said
more people were displaced by extreme
weather-related disasters in 2020 than
by conflict
just one example in may this year in
afghanistan heavy rain and floods
triggered an estimated 16 000
displacements across 14 provinces
bangladesh is one of the most climate
vulnerable countries in the world it's
low-lying and frequently hit by serious
storms such as cyclone and fan in 2020
it's predicted that by 2050 one in seven
people in bangladesh will be forced from
their homes due to climate change
in the future we're likely to see more
of these displacements climate change
could displace more than 200 million
people within their own country by 2050
according to the world bank
and while that prediction is for
internally displaced people the
conditions created by climate change add
to the issue of international migration
andrew harper is special adviser to the
high commissioner for climate action at
the un refugee agency andrew harper
thanks very much indeed for being with
us how much do climate events extreme
weather events
impact on migration can we
identify that can we
put a number on it
well i think the the figures that you
mentioned before are particularly
valid and that is
last year there was some 30 million
people that were displaced due to
extreme weather events
and that is one person per second
so if that doesn't grab attention i
don't know what does
but that also doesn't take into account
people have been displaced due to longer
term impacts such as desert vacation or
sea level rise but what we're
particularly concerned about is how
climate change and extreme weather
events are complicating already fraught
situations
so we've already got tens of millions of
people who have been displaced by
conflict
but what we're looking at is people
being displaced by conflict having their
lives made even more
challenging even more vulnerable by the
uh by the situation of climate change
and by extreme weather events if you
look at the situation in south sudan at
the moment we're talking to colleagues
at the moment who are trying to put up
earth and walls to protect the camps
we were talking to
colleagues in the sahel who have had to
deal with a shortened rain season and
that's going to lead to food insecurity
so across the board we're seeing the
impact of climate change not necessarily
driving uh people away but contributing
to underlying
vulnerabilities uh aggravating
underlying grievances and that's causing
people to move and in your role andrew
as you've described you witnessed this
first hand
who feels the impacts of this the
hardest
well the
not the people who are probably
attending cop26 it's the it's the people
who are not there who are being impacted
the most and that's because the people
with the least resources
and often the
the lowest in terms of voice
have got the least capacity to adapt
to
the impact of climate change so if you
come from a developed world uh from like
countries with high incomes then you can
change you can change your lifestyle you
can adapt but if you've got nothing
and you're you're relying on the on the
food that you were able to salvage from
last year and that's get washed away
then what do you do so what we're seeing
around the world at the moment is
extremely vulnerable populations being
suffering body blow after body blow and
then sort of saying okay like what do we
do next and this is one of the big
reasons why
there's such a push for support for
adaptation and building resilience
people do not want to leave despite the
impression in the west people would
prefer if they've got a choice to remain
with their communities but let's give
them that choice let's build the
resilience let's support refugees where
they are and the hosts who are so
generously providing the protection that
they need and often without that much
gratitude or resources
andrew harper good to hear from you
thank you thank you
in some of today's other climate news
china's carbon emissions have fallen for
the first time since its economic
recovery from the coronavirus began
according to the analysis from the
carbon brief website the world's biggest
polluter saw co2 emissions drop by
around 0.5
in the third quarter of 2021 compared to
a year earlier the drop is partly as a
result of a clampdown on property
development and widespread coal
shortages
water companies in england and wales
issued more than 5
500 alerts of sewage being discharged
into coastal waters in the last year
that's according to a report from
surfers against sewage who say the
pollution is a result of storm overflows
the uk government has handed the oil and
gas industry 13.6 billion pounds in
subsidies since the landmark paris
climate accord was signed in 2015
according to analysis by campaign group
paid to pollute if approved the cambo
oil field northwest of the shetland
isles could also benefit from tax breaks
and payments towards decommissioning
costs environmentalists argue that the
oil field is incompatible with the paris
agreement targets and shouldn't go ahead
the results are in from this year's
great british beach clean and they're
looking positive more than five tons of
litter was collected by dedicated
volunteers who recorded an average of
385 items on each beach dropping from
425 in 2020 the amount of litter
collected is the lowest recorded yet
although 75
of the rubbish was plastic
last week we reported on air pollution
levels in delhi which had reached such
high levels that authorities were forced
to close down some coal-fired power
stations
now the pakistani authorities are
sending anti-smog squads to track down
the biggest polluters in lahore which
has been top of the list of the world's
most polluted cities this week
i asked dr asif qatar assistant
professor of environmental scientists
sciences at the university of peshawa in
pakistan about the scale of the problem
we do have air pollution problems in
pakistan and the reason why lahore is
experiencing um a very thick smog
for the last couple of weeks is is
because of the uncontrolled pollution
and we have a lot of vehicle emissions
which are actually contributing to the
smog so during the winter season there's
a lot of condensation in the lower
atmosphere due to which we have the fog
being produced
so when the smoke from the vehicles and
the industries and the nearby brick
kilns it combines with the fog then the
smog is produced what impact does that
smog have on the residents of lahore so
the the main impacts are health impacts
which
we can see
being directly
influencing the residents of lahore for
example
those patients who already have asthma
their asthma it becomes more severe or
if they have copd
that can become severe
but we also see
those residents who do not have any
underlying health conditions who can
also suffer
for example eye irritation throat
irritation
this is a very common as a result of the
smog so it has direct impacts on the
human health
and frighteningly
serious impacts on life expectancy oh
absolutely yes according to a recent
study by the university of chicago
they have mentioned in in one of their
reports that the life expen expectancy
overall in pakistan it is reduced by two
years due to air pollution but in lahore
it is reduced to more than five years
is there the political will to try and
find a solution and get the emissions
down
so certainly um mondays are off for
schools and offices and hopefully that
should reduce the commuting and the
emissions
but in terms of the political will yes i
think the government has the political
will
but there are certain
capacities which need to be built up for
example the pollution control
technologies which need to be
implemented and those are unfortunately
lacking to a greater extent in in
pakistan so if we can improve the
pollution control technologies
particularly when we talk about
emissions from the industries so if we
have these filtration plants
electrostatic precipitators as well as
even scrubbers they will make a huge
difference in terms of the emissions and
then the other problem the main problem
is actually from the vehicle so there
are many vehicles which are very old and
if we can have
controls um for the emissions if we can
actually implement the existing
legislation that will bring a huge
difference doctor assaf qatar
now capturing carbon dioxide and
converting it to oxygen sounds like the
perfect climate solution and that's what
the cultivation of micro algae can do
and now one company has managed to
harness the process in order to create
an award-winning carbon-negative drink
sarah christina and i first came across
spirulina which is a tiny blue-green
algae when we're researching food
solutions to our climate crisis
[Music]
we were determined to unlock the true
human and climate health potential of
spirulina
[Music]
no arable land required no fertilizers
pesticides very limited fresh water
unlike a lot of other crops but what we
do use
is the co2 that we recycle from other
industrial waste streams
[Music]
do stay tuned because coming up after
the break i'll be joined by climate
scientist dr ella gilbert and anna
markova the policy officer for industry
and climate at the trades union congress
we're going to be discussing what can be
done to address the issue of climate
change-induced migration and how
seriously the uk government is taking
the green transition we'll see you in a
couple of minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
they push the protesters further back
here as around two or three hundred
still remain
i'm dan white head and i'm sky news's
west of england correspondent
[Music]
this fan goes on to the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities are at the moment
a lifesaver
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the high street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the hearts of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the eu but the trade stopped
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
blake
i'd all be
finished i don't know
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know if you use less energy we
can reduce air pollution
like turning off the lights yep
[Music]
storm arwin will bring some disruption
over the next few days after a frosty
start in the southeast rain will clear
across the south on friday morning to
leave a scattering of blustery showers
there'll be some wintriness on the hills
the wind will pick up in the north and
west too the afternoon we'll see more
general rain sleet and snow in the north
with severe coastal gales developing in
the northeast the clean northerly flow
does mean that air pollution levels will
remain low with values of two or three
on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with climate
scientists dr ella gilbert and anna
markova the policy officer for industry
and climate at the tuc
now earlier on the show we heard how
climate change is forcing millions of
people across the world to leave their
homes and their livelihoods it is fast
becoming one of the main causes of
forced migration and the situation is
likely to get much worse without urgent
action the un secretary general has said
climate change is now found to be the
key factor accelerating all other
drivers of force displacement so ella
given the urgency of this what needs to
be done
well we need to make sure that the kinds
of climate impacts which are driving
people to either leave their homes
within and move within their countries
or to move internationally are addressed
and i mean the primary thing that we
need to do is make sure that this
doesn't get any worse and that means
tackling climate change by reducing our
emissions
anna whose responsibility is it is it
the responsibility of richer nations to
help those who are most vulnerable
absolutely i mean i think the key kind
of principle to lay down is we all want
to treat others how we expect to be
treated everyone who experiences the
loss of livelihood everyone who
experiences the loss of safety deserves
um you know sanctuary if they're seeking
sanctuary and safety if they're seeking
if they're seeking alternative
livelihood so um you know the countries
that are experiencing the worst uh
impact in terms of climate change
they're actually losing land
farmland other resources are the
countries that have uh done the least to
um to cause the the global heating that
we're experiencing and uh the uk and
other rich countries have the resources
to fund the adaptation have the
resources to fund uh the sort of um loss
and damage um
that um that these countries have been
requesting um so that's what we need to
do we've got the resources to do it and
the uk
particularly as it still holds the corp
presidency should use this moment really
and its international influence and its
resources to finance um adaptation and
loss of damage
and
ella it's not just an issue for poorer
nations is it if you look at what's
happening in canada right now you look
to the us during hurricane season the
australian wildfires what we saw in
europe
over the summer those extreme weather
events causing internal displacement
is it surprising then that there isn't
more urgency about this more urgent
action being taken
when we put it like that maybe it's
surprising but the the fact of the
matter is that if it doesn't affect us
directly or we don't think it affects us
directly we're more um likely to to
ignore it and pretend it's not an issue
the thing is it's going to affect all of
us it already affects all of us climate
impacts are being felt
here in the uk they're being felt in
canada they're being felt in the usa
they're being felt in the developing and
developed world and the fact is it's
going to get worse especially if we do
the little we're doing already to adapt
and to mitigate climate change the more
warming we see in the future the more
devastating these impacts are going to
become and we absolutely have to do
everything that we can to make sure that
the worst impacts of climate change are
avoided
and what about those climate finance and
adaptation pledges made at cop 26 then
anna are they going to make any
difference
of course every
step makes a difference and i think uh
the acknowledgement that the issues of
adaptation loss and damage just
transition have had at cop26 are steps
forward but you know so far mostly it's
words uh so far
we have not seen anywhere near the
amount of financing that the most
effective country affected countries are
actually requesting
and the other thing is um one of the
things that you know i was in in the
global trade union delegation at uh cop
26 and one of the things that we were
really calling for is that climate
finance that money that rich countries
put in to help uh poorer countries adapt
or mitigate
climate change
that that those funds uh must be
genuinely fit for purpose that they must
have safeguards to protect human rights
including indigenous rights including
women's rights including labor rights
and that's not something that we've seen
yet so there's a lot
a lot of work still to be done in terms
of international negotiations and even
more work to be done in terms of
securing the right amount of resource
let's move on to topic number two a
campaign group paid to pollute has
claimed that the uk government has given
nearly 14 billion pounds to oil and gas
companies since the paris agreement was
signed comes just weeks after cop 26
countries including the uk committed
there to phasing down inefficient fuel
subsidies as part of the glasgow climate
pact boris johnson told world leaders
they needed to match action to their
promises on fighting climate change but
is his own government doing
enough uh anna the the paid to pollute
uh report out today is is talking about
well all talk and no action from the
government is that a fair assessment
i think so and i particularly wanted to
draw attention to one element of this um
of this report of this of of the
estimates so um the report says that um
there were uh 3.7 billion pounds issued
as new subsidies for decommissioning of
oil and gas rigs
um and what's happening at the moment is
it's effectively kind of like dumping
that money in the sea it's the
government is paying oil companies um
instead of the companies taking
responsibility themselves the government
is paying oil companies to
um remove aging oil rigs and a lot of
the time because of the way that this
policy is set up a lot of the time what
ends up happening is they just end up
getting towed away let's say and left on
a beach in bangladesh to sort of just
sort of sit there and rust or to be kind
of recycled in in a sort of informal
economy with people getting paid poverty
wages or less
so really um you know that money isn't
isn't fit for purpose that policy isn't
fit for purpose we need something a lot
better than that
boris johnson talks about the uk
building back greener but this is going
to take concerted and coordinated effort
from all sectors
how do we ensure they have the climate
leadership and know what to do in order
to make that happen
well i think it's
it's true that we we know already what
we need to do we need to dramatically
change the way our economy is structured
and we need to change where our our
money is invested and to be quite frank
the government is saying one thing and
doing the complete opposite the actions
it's taking you know investing in new
oil fields or investing in new coal
mines or
subsidizing fossil fuel companies or
expanding airports is completely counter
to what they've promised as the
president of the cop and also after cop
26 and
inc is completely inconsistent with all
of their targets to to meet uh under the
the paris agreement and the glasgow pact
it's completely inconsistent and what
they actually need to be doing is
withdrawing subsidies for fossil fuels
investing in cleaner greener solutions
creating green jobs and accelerating
that transition to a society where we
don't have to rely on these ancient
old technologies that aren't going to
get us anywhere and anna what about on a
more local level cities businesses
making net zero pledges too how do they
turn those into concrete action
so absolutely every uh it's great to see
that lots more businesses are pledging
uh to reach net zero missions by um such
and such days um and same from towns the
same from regions uh but from that you
need to build to an actual plan and um
we've done um our own polling a little
while ago on uh kind of what the uk
workforce thinks of um how the green
transition is being planned and what we
found was yes we all want to see that
transition happening and only one in
four um workers in uk have said that
they've had a chance to feed back to
their employer on their ideas okay what
has to happen i'm really sorry to cut
you off anna and ella we are out of time
thank you very much indeed coming up
next sky news is going to be live in
calais for a special program on the
deaths of 27 people trying to cross the
english channel thanks for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you